oder was geht hier vor max und herzlich
willkommen zu einer dieser typischen ich
überlege mir einen dummen hashtag und
lass mir darunter frage stellen momenten
dabei spielen heute ein bisschen rock it
liegt und der heutige hashtag ist
versteckt flaschen deckel weil ich hatte
gerade in verstecke familie als mir das
einfallen lassen hatte einfallen lassen
in der partie whatever ich habe schon
geschickt okay in papua auf die fragen
kommen gerade richtig
heavy rain glaube auch dass diese
vorschrift verdammt versteckten man
diese fortgeschrittene uhrzeit die frage
wie dieses aufnehmen
wie groß bist du dankeschön für sehr
knapp kein problem
wie groß bist du ich bin ein mädchen 89
das steht zumindest steht zumindest in
meinem ausweis man sie besser
nein mein auto aussieht aber hat er das
rechtfertige für drei jahre hat nicht
geregelt ein tor zu schießen
wieso hashtag flaschen decke eine
distanz wenn sich entscheiden sie uns
was für ein super jetzt sein dürfte es
welcher wärst du und warum ich glaube
ich wäre ironman weil meine entscheide
ich der typ hat lula des todes also es
so reich und der kann sich entscheiden
war ein superheld sein möchte die
anderen leute fliegen die ganzen kann
ich mir auch von mir die kopfhörer aus
dem auto steigen die anderen weil wie so
gibt er beim 2 1 auf sehr positiv wir
gehen einfach ins nächste spiel
die anderen leute sind halt immer so
ihre super helm sowie halt also ich bin
jetzt ein bisschen beide wenders aber
trotzdem irgendwie wäre das glaube ich
ganz ehrlich ich kann deinen namen
bestimmt nicht richtig aussprechen kalt
lassen
pizza oder döner ich mache mir gerade
eine pizza
ist
es könnte sein dass ich gleich kurz weg
muss da hat es sehr ärgerlich
verdammt wenn meine pizza ist verbrannt
ok damit habe ich nicht gerechnet
freunde ich bin ein bisschen gestresst
weil ihr wisst ja wie das ist mit mir
und four produzieren und dass er jetzt
noch wakeskate bin ich schon recht ich
habe mir keinen abwurf lange macht
richtung denn dann das geht bald los und
ich habe noch kein abo so ist es immer
wenn ich wollt ihr also macht euch keine
sorgen kann man dich die kann man nicht
in jeder lebenslage erheitern
man kann ich nicht in jeder lebenslage
erhalten
also irgendwie schon bestimmt aber da
ist kein allgemein rezept das wäre viel
zu einfach ich mal wenn ihr einfach
immer wenn ihr traurig seite so was wir
jetzt wo ich mir eine pizza chips
ich war zehn minuten zu früh da meine
pizza aber auch noch zehn minuten und
ich bin gerade die treppe hoch gefallen
hier bereitet gehört schafft was ja
zu kommen jetzt hat der typ für 20 wurde
überhaupt unwahrscheinlich freunde
handelt
aber nein man sich verdienen bist du ein
herrschen deckel nein ist hashtags noch
zusammen freuen
interessiert euch wann kommt wieder was
mit jörg das ist mir aufgefallen hat mir
auch genervt in letzter zeit dass ich so
lange nicht mit justin hochgeladen habe
das lag daran er war im urlaub und ich
habe es probiert mit so ein bisschen
bisschen anderen konten zu machen liegt
also ich das klingt nicht wieder ein
bisschen bisschen aber ich gemacht hast
du immer noch unglaublich gerne behaupte
einfach mal er mich auch aber das hat
nichts mit irgendwas zu tun das finde
ich zusammen aufgenommen sondern einfach
er beim urlaub ich war ganz lange weg
und hat sich deshalb einfach lange zeit
mit ihr geben aber das kommen bestimmt
wieder videos zusammen und tauchten wir
euch fünf wollen wenn ihr machen gerne
mit dieser typ der nur glück nur welche
aufgabe hat rezepturen tut mir leid an
die ganzen leute die ich jetzt aufregen
aber sollten ja sowieso fragen im
vordergrund stehen freut sich schon sehr
auf weiß und wenn ja auch was am meisten
spaß nicht
geht mir leid an die jüngeren zuschauer
werde höchste wörter sagt
tschüss
was würde ich sagen
wollte
ich freue mich bedeuten
ich freue mich allerdings auf wales und
am meisten würde ich sagen ich mich
natürlich auch für die fan fiction es
musste ich das jetzt natürlich aber ich
freue mich auf die landschaft way zum
suchen glaubt die schönen landschaften
der welt ist komplett andere also als
ferienort und dieses auf die ausbildung
hier merke ich fokussiere
hallo auf gott tut mir leid leute ich
habe es nicht gesehen
tui deutschland ist eine schande
ich bin ein schlechter als player sagt
schreibt es spricht es einfach aus in
den kommentaren was ihr euch die ganze
zeit denkt schreibt einfach sei denn ihr
seid apple player funktioniert das ganze
dorf einigermaßen aber ich glaube seit
er in die keller zweites
wenn sich spätestens jetzt lächelt wenn
ihm auf mit irgendwelchen komischen
überlegungen die cloud ausführen und
wird man muss ja nicht in frage ist
martina seine zwillingsschwester ja ich
hab ich würde schon öfters gefragt
es heißt übrigens martina nicht martina
die heißt ja sogar so ähnlich wie ich ja
tatsächlich
wir sind verwandt nicht gesagt wie wir
ich kenne sich aber das verhältnis der
luft und die liebe
sehr tief befriedigt
wer darf eigentlich nicht gewinnen der
lappen weil der wie sie geschrieben und
einfach zwei tore gemacht als ich aber
gut kann man kann man also mit ihm
keinesfalls verübeln weil man geht
einfach nicht erfährt man spielt
aber er soll nicht wie sie schreiben und
wenn er nur fühlt weil der tore gemacht
hat als ich etwa daher
oder hat er einst hatte er gut angefühlt
auch so gemacht und als ob euroshop ag
hat jetzt bis sonntag getroffen dass wir
gewinnen kann ich der decke zu deiner
flache sein
zu meiner flache juristen schlechter
verlierer sein wenn wir sagen man kann
sein dass du ein bisschen schlechter
verlierer willst du kleiner forum
welches der deutschland berechtigt aber
herum hat keine bedeutung also keine
andere antwort ob gott jetzt hatte ich
die kopfhörer hier wenn du jetzt ein tor
gemacht hat dann hast mein leben so gut
wir besiegen den erst freunde ich bin
nicht mehr scheiße in wittlich
kennt ihr das wenn man sich so an so
konzentriert auf dem spiel
und dann da irgendwelche komischen
grimassen zu machen das macht hier und
wir gern vor das war gut kennt ihr
mindestens aus der alten mario kart zeit
zu alledem bei irgendwelchen reihen also
was im reisebus zusammen mario kart
gespielt haben vorausgesetzt ihr gehört
dieser generation an wo man es getan hat
kann ich nur seine alten spiele ich
vollständig ich hoffe dass gewinnen kann
wir sind gespannt wie der zweirad black
beats und vielleicht im business man
liest usedsoft also freunde aber ihr
könntet den chat gar nicht sehen er hat
beschrieben facti und geschrieben [ __ ]
you in the water freunde
das gehört sich nicht aber ich muss
meine freunde da bin ich jetzt auch
wieder hier ist meine pizza seit
neidisch tschüss herr staeck wie findest
du fliegen dann auch noch ein paar spa
suite fragen ich mag es eigentlich zu
fliegen aber manchmal diese turbulenzen
sind cool wirst du auf ihr dabei sein so
weit ich weiß ja hast du schon
irgendjemanden abgeleckt keiner keiner
aussage das ist zwar keine frage aber
schlampig so griffen mit aufnahmen
hast du tube clash 1 geguckt nicht
vollständig hast du flugangst nein
wie findest du zombies gruselig tschüss
das war's von heute leute alle fragen
beantwortet ich hoffe es war nicht allzu
und rufe doch was und ja bis zum
nächsten